[Music]
oh god
guess what
well if you didn't want if you want to
put me to sleep remember when thick boy
brandon shop
uh i had a showtime show that about
review reviewing food trucks
well it's on youtube now um now we're
gonna watch it okay and i want you to
understand that what we're doing bent
pixels is called transformative content
we're providing transformative
commentary and this will make up a very
small part of our show and we're just
going to be skipping around this video
as we do with everything else that we
cover which is covered under us
copyright law and our playing of some of
these uh snippets is also not if in any
way affecting uh your ability for people
to come and watch the full video either
so correct i just want to make that
clear so you can watch this whole video
by searching for tim kennedy food truck
diary that we're promoting
we're helping now we're going to review
it
we flew him all the way from austin
texas he
austin scissors i like austin texas well
austin's houses we got to go to austin
my favorite wrestler was stone cold
steve austin yeah i like steve austin
the 6 million man too oh that's a good
one too you're right i forgot about that
i still want to like maybe go to austin
someday maybe do some infowars stuff
yeah that'd be really fun yeah he's a
former ufc middleweight he's a special
forces badass and a recent new author
on today's food truck diaries it's tim
kennedy and i'm feeding him trapping
wings he's phenom
how does this age it's a question i have
right
how does this age this is like this came
out two days ago and it doesn't age not
good now but that's my point though but
you picked up what i'm saying like
this fuckboy persona that he has because
that's what it is it's a fuckboy this is
a this is like a 10 year old persona
yeah that like was cool 10 years ago
yeah it's like this doesn't like age
well you know the worst thing jon
stewart had to look back on when he
became professionals he stopped wearing
leather jackets but he was still
essentially the same guy you know what i
mean like this person like
what does a 60 year old brendan look
like
dressed like this just old and sounding
even more [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
i've never seen this stick his wallet
stick dude
[Music]
i need everything i get super thick boy
huh brendan you're a [ __ ]
embarrassment is there a full version of
the song i needed in my life thick i
could look it up after this you know
what i need it i need the full song of
my life
no i'm not seeing it i'll figure we'll
find it so one of the fans will find it
i need that i need the full thick boy
song
don't worry you might get it in this
intro yeah how long is this intro
late yeah one minute
yeah
mr tim kennedy
one of my favorite people in the game
cause
it's food truck diaries right
thick boy's his production company yes
so do most shows have a theme song
for the intro about the production
company i don't think so
i don't remember a worldwide pant song
before letterman
i don't remember all the the tgi friday
shows all having the same theme song and
it was all about miller boy yet
wait i don't know is step by step on
earth family matters i don't even know
which one's on they just play the same
theme song
well make me proud to be an american i
like that every law and order is just
dick wolf [ __ ] dick wolf [ __ ]
skirt
yeah me too and every show on the bbc's
bbc bravo
but it's done in the style of a grime
rapper from the uk that's right it's
because it's like tcp funded y'all love
in it
in it yeah i think we're
living free because of people like you
my man well there's lots of people like
me so that's that's that's fun yeah i
don't know them though yeah i just try
to keep up with them because i'm gonna
skip ahead from the small talk is that
cool
yeah you'll have to skip ahead like 40
minutes okay let's get to scars and
stripes okay let's throw in top gun
obviously i'm dude i don't want to run
like jock take this leaf and he's like
i'm going to describe this leaf to you
and the way he talks i'm just like oh my
god don't
dude he could read harry potter you go
guys word of advice i'm not going to
tell you how to do your food truck show
but maybe don't do coke and adderall
before you eat the tacos like or
whatever your wings don't usually you
want to eat and then get a couple bumps
in
i'm not saying that you guys are on cook
but i'm also saying that you're not yeah
jordan peterson
unconscious yes he's brilliant yes
jordan peterson another brilliant dude
who i could listen to paint yeah he'd
talk about paint dry and i'd be like oh
man bro this guy
this sounds like you know what this do
you know what this chemistry is usc
fighter i get it but he's just it's it's
energy is annoying energy right
and they're different energies and they
yeah
these are
this this chemistry this feels like
two like all right say there's two women
that are friends from work
this is the husband's meeting each other
and actually getting getting along yeah
but they don't know like this is two
strangers talking to each other awkward
bro bro bro you watched game of thrones
oh [ __ ] i love that [ __ ] man
dude hang on live i'm not going to live
here will you ever check out like jordan
peterson man bro i watch your [ __ ] like
all the time dude exactly what it's like
two guys meeting each other for the
first time at a barbecue
i'm in let's talk about so you got to
know each other for a long time like me
and royce so now there's a lot of lulls
of silence in between we can be in the
middle of vegas and it'll be like
[ __ ] 10 minutes of silence and then
hey
check out that waitresses
exactly that's just
nice
he just go back to you exactly
yes he's brilliant yes jordan peterson
another brilliant dude who i could
listen to paint yeah he could talk about
paint drying i'd be like i'm in two more
i'm in let's talk about uh sports
instruments
yeah that's good
sports drill masking
covers and i'm like i'm out on this one
but usually i'm on board maybe not
topics
well before our cameras melt because the
120 degrees i hope this video ends with
a [ __ ] a sniper that really hates the
color pink
i'm sure you've been in way worse
conditions but you weren't expecting it
here for food trust no no let's go to
california now how some al-qaeda guy
comes back to try to kill tim kennedy
and he's got a sniper rifle up there but
he's so [ __ ] distracted by that pink
pink hat that he shoots brendan instead
this is for my brothers out of principle
no yeah that's what it is he actually
he's just looking and he's he's got
[ __ ] tim kennedy right in his
crosshairs
looking at him through the scope and
he's got his shot and then she's like
i cannot help it this other man he is
just so enraging
i know i am going to blow my chance oh
[ __ ]
take a little break from talking to one
of the greatest americans of all time my
boy tim kennedy because listen greater
than george washington um
better john adams yes that's correct
better than benjamin franklin that's
right okay
like tim kennedy if you want to be in
shape these days but you don't want to
go to the gym but then you're not going
to knock it in shape that's then you're
not going i'm going to the gym and i'm
not in shape whatever you're about to
say is absolutely now a lie right like
we don't know what the product is yet we
don't know what you're shilling but
whatever you're shilling is a lie it's
no matter what you just based the
premise on something you can't do i go
to the gym five days a week six days a
week and i'm nodding yeah i know okay so
whatever magic thing your whatever magic
beans you're selling there brendan i'm
buying them
but you want to get that sweating and
you're busy you got kids you got work
you got all sorts of things going on for
math
oh math
man you need the peloton that's on my
what did he call a peloton
a peloton no
no
we're hearing that again
man you need the peloton that's the
pilot
close enough now my thick ass got into
the bike world i've had a peloton for
six years now i started riding my bike
remember that time he made up that story
about saving a family from a burning car
oh god
and a bunch of people forgot about that
memory hold that doing 30 minute
workouts 20 minute workout home bike
yeah
robin i love it now let's take this to
the streets next thing you know i
launched a bike club
i love peloton next thing you know
he's launched a bike club he's reading
the copy they give him yeah
verbatim this is all lies yeah
because like we get copy like that right
and all the companies go look
we just wrote that as an example but do
what you want with it but if you didn't
you know we we obviously don't have the
people guys started a [ __ ] bike club
but this is the part where you're gonna
insert your own thing
where you can
somehow realistically say you enjoyed it
right
which is why it's easy for us sometimes
it's why we turn down a lot of sponsors
because sometimes we're like
there's no way we're gonna be able to
[ __ ] people into thinking we
actually like this and we're not gonna
lie but he just literally read the copy
of the suggested thing that you could
say like oh yeah i even started my own
peloton bike club
yeah
once no you didn't
man and they have so much to offer you
guys listen they have world-class
instructors ready to motivate you 24 7.
all right they have thousands of live
classes which i recommend but if you
can't the on-demand classes are ready
whenever you want but it's an exercise
bike right
who needs a class for that
see that exercise bike i have there
functions the exact same way as the
peloton does except it doesn't have a
monitor right so it comes with a monitor
on the internet right and then you do
you do a live class with people if you
want
you know what i do on my when i use the
bike
i put tucker on and i ride the bike and
i watch that because i'm not going to
pay that was 2016
who wants to ride fake inside bikes with
people
riding bikes outside of people's fun
yeah inside bikes has worked so
if i wanted that experience i would just
get this thing they have it's called
a gym membership
they have many bikes but you know they
also have
a bunch of other [ __ ]
and noon 1 p.m
11 a.m whatever you need yeah
there's all kinds of times
yeah are you going to name all of them
he's naming all the time 1104
you got
order he's gonna 816.
him
no yeah dudes one of my favorites is
like 3 30 like two
it's right around a good time to start
having your first drink i love his
libraries all right let's get to the to
the food
how you doing man
uh what do you recommend here man
appreciate you doing this it is the
wings
[Music]
they're talking to the food truck guy
how you doing man what do you recommend
when they specifically went out there
just for this
that's in a parking lot like
where he lives and also why don't you
let the guy why don't you ask the guy if
he wants to be in a youtube video yeah
why why you notice it's it's a small
detail
but notice there's a bit of narcissism
here where it's like me and tim kennedy
people want to look at us two studs and
they don't care about you but like
that's
just arrogance and like narcissism a
normal person would go no let's set this
shot up there's so much have you seen a
guy fieri move like that's what i was
just about to point out
so much you show the guy there's so much
room here from brendan's back they could
have moved it over showed the guy in a
truck i was gonna specifically say guy
fiori you watch his shows
and he makes sure you go and meet the
dishwasher and like the cooks and stuff
and he like like he gets you know he
knows that yeah he's the main guy in the
show
but the show's charm is that you're
gonna go meet some old [ __ ] dude
that's in his 60s and his [ __ ]
apron's a [ __ ] mess but he's just
pulling [ __ ]
giant racks of ribs out of the smoke all
day and you're like okay this guy's cool
let's see what you know any that's what
you want to see these guys don't get
that it's just oh no man we're just
going to talk about more about mma and
like fireworks and sneakers and [ __ ] so
fireworks we're going to talk about like
4th of july and like cbd and [ __ ] yo
what do you recommend at the wing drug
dog i don't know the wings
too
they all sell the names themselves you
got like the baby mama i'm in on that
one og hot buffalo move the camera
there's a line behind them when you're
[ __ ] right there how great would that
be
it pans back and
you see more people coming to the line
as it's getting bigger
they pan to the left and lewis from the
specials is next to them i just want to
eat
look i'm really i'm just sort of i'm
really just eating my sadness right now
so i'm in on that one
you know the honey sriracha absolutely
and then and then louis meets gets to
meet brendan schaub and brendan chop's
like sorry man i'm trying to do my
youtube thing you know who i am and he's
like oh yeah you're a [ __ ] fella
from america
all right
you're that [ __ ]
mango habanero so like should we just do
like a mix and you and i just dive in
like but a plethora like a couple el
guapo would say
yeah we've all seen three amigos tim
all seen it
right it was like your five best flavors
and definitely the sauce 64.
like 10 of each and we'll just
no problem go go crazy yeah i mean look
like look at this guy we're not nice
he's a thick boy bros are the worst
dude this looks awesome yeah this is
fantastic fake bronis is what's annoying
i don't even mind bros when you see like
bro dudes out that are really bros
like it's kind of endearing when you see
them out like you know like we've seen
it in
pretty much everywhere we go on the road
there'll always be some
young group of dude bros in their early
20s just being asked like being [ __ ]
but having fun and you're like cool this
is forced to bronest this is come do my
youtube channel because the algorithm
says
you know my pr people said that tim tim
kennedy brendan shaw video is going to
do good in the algorithm they estimate
i'll make 800 a month on the the clip
like they they have it all figured out
it's just there's no there's no just not
dudes hanging out exactly but look at
that you don't think that's natural
he's like here's if we're gonna do this
also the sprite um
but uh
now last time you were on food truck so
he's doing hot ones you know yeah he's
doing hot water he's doing hot ones you
know would be awesome
is if he [ __ ]
he's sitting there just covered in wing
sauce and he's like so tell me about
this book and he reaches over and picks
the book up and just starts like turning
thumbing
yeah actually i brought it this is this
is crazy i can't believe i can't believe
him
this book all right was actually one of
the one of the one of the last one of
the last books
that was signed by the by the navy seal
that killed bin laden so like that guy
passed away and it's the only one we
have and then it's just been it brendan
opening it up with wing sauce
oh yeah dude this part right here in the
book bro it's [ __ ] awesome brendan
what are you doing he's just smudging
the [ __ ] smudging the signature
oh here's the here's the twist oh yeah
you don't read the title of his book
stars no scars and stripes
um
it it's um
yeah because cauliflower here and dead
iraqi children wasn't as
was in the focus group testing it's not
worthy it was too wordy
but no it'd be even funnier because look
we got this copy of this book it's the
only one signed by the seal that killed
bin laden and you open up the front
cover and it's blank yeah
because they didn't
god kyle kyle white goes brendan's like
yo bro where are the pictures well he's
going through the book
uh
i won't say the name of the truck but
they were steamed burgers
and i was so embarrassed steamed hams
you're thinking of a simpsons episode
wait steamed hams yeah
as a texan if you're like hey i'm going
to take this meat
and i'm going to steam it what are we
doing you lost me i was out too i'm
going to take moisture and water and i'm
going to cook meat with it i'm like
i'm going to take all the juiciness out
and just get what he's trying to do the
opposite of that you'd be steep
he's an idiot
he's saying the opposite thing i'm gonna
i'm gonna skip ahead dealing with stress
let's do that i get like your mental
space it must just be
like either you're just bro you brought
this up the other day when we were
talking about them and you're 100 right
the words they use mental space they're
just repeating what their therapists
tell them
like the the these la comics are weak
first off and they're so weak that it's
that same like my therapist said you
know that i need to actually express my
mind space better mm-hmm like what what
does that even mean yeah
and and then meanwhile you go to like
you know the east coast and it's like
louis j gomez is yelling at enterprise
around a car being like you better
[ __ ] give me a couple free days dawg
i found cocaine in my car
does brendan
have a picture of joe rogan behind him
yeah of course what is this
it's the keith's the goat what
it's the cool rogan head shot too
remember the one we had all the guns
pointed out yeah yeah the one that they
did to john mcafee too yeah oh so cool
man but it made sense when it did to
mcafee um
what are you so
used to it and you know how to handle it
or
you know
you you're
do you see a therapist like how do you
deal with this because you see someone's
got a really good point there it is
therapist he even said he just said it
good call sorry i got distracted because
somebody brought up a point
you're not going to finish what's in
your mouth before asking the question
well no
there it is that's a freeze frame that's
because house one goes for first
he looks like a gorilla can i ask you
something royce
if he wasn't chewing on wings would we
understand what he [ __ ] said but at
least i wouldn't see wings in his mouth
that's the upside
used to it and you know how to handle it
or
you know
you you're
do you see a therapist like how do you
deal with this because you see the worst
of the worst in the world but honestly
my my
therapy is doing more work
you know i not that the greater good is
ever
because a great good could be used to oh
self-fully justify here we go
rationalize horrible things but hey be
careful you don't want to suck your own
dick with all that hot sauce on your
they call that a mouth [ __ ]
approach says man if i if i can keep
going out and doing good and doing well
in change and you know helping america
you could change
and we could change that's all it takes
and he just beats the [ __ ] out of you
how they know it's into a coma
he has a short fuse he kills me both of
these men could [ __ ] me up i want to be
clear here before anybody goes dude kick
your ass i know they can't of course
they can't but they're not going to
america no because that's illegal and
let's sue them sir
that's illegal yeah and both of them
have significantly more money than us
so we're kind of at the in the advantage
here i'll get knocked out for a payday
are you kidding me people always say oh
you're jealous of them they should be
jealous of us we have all the bargaining
position here i can make fun of you
forever and if you hit me you're going
to be poorer and maybe in jail i'll tell
you what man i'll remodel that into an
rot rotc west studio if you keep [ __ ]
around trying to hit me people keep
saying that like would i talk this kind
of [ __ ] to a guy that tough who also has
nothing to lose probably no he'll kill
you probably not
but you know come on it's adam says red
bar said it right that's not allowed
that's what he said
when he responded to joey diaz saying he
was gonna take a baseball bat to jules
face
and he's like and by the way i'm gonna
keep making fun of you now and you can't
hit me that's not allowed
that's very funny very true because
policies overseas and saving more
people's lives
when the plane's taken off from
afghanistan and i'm thinking about the
tens of thousands of people i left
behind you're like that could kill you
like the women and children that
literally have to be like you have to
stay i can't bring you in no literally i
did is he
brendan shut up and then i'm finished
you hear him
tell women that not for me you know but
i'm also sitting on this plane on the
c17 i'm looking around all right pause
for that explain to me about how you're
doing all this like you know you know
marine yeah all right so anyway i was
over there in afghanistan and there was
this family right this family had like
this they just lost their dad
and um you know they were struggling
they couldn't make it how are the wings
[Laughter]
i was going to tell you how i held a
dying child in my arms but yeah the
wings are good
cool
anyway this has been
anyway peloton bike
let's talk to you about blue chew
you know when you're getting blown in
the parking lot of a car
of the [ __ ] lap factory i'm brendan
job and you know what my brain might not
work but my dick sure does thanks to
bruchu
yo when you're [ __ ] a dime piece
makes my dick swell up like my ears
by the way you know what those wings
could use a little
no
there are people on this plane and all
of them for the first time are breathing
a breath of word word word word word
word with the taliban they can relax you
can relax and then i'm already thinking
like what is my next thing that i can do
what is my next mission that i'm gonna
do you almost don't have time to focus
on that exactly just just keep moving
you're like you know in a fight when um
the fight's not going exactly according
to plan
you know do i focus on the weight just
give me a head
to military now military family seems
dumb sampler platter this guy who's the
skinny one you just walked in
we got wings for days for you
to put some meat on you
before we try all these and sign out of
here
um next feed man just keep pushing the
book
saving lives
one more week book stuff
two days a quarter wings now i'm [ __ ]
starving this was a successful video in
that god damn it brendan you piece of
[ __ ]
anyway apprentice shop sucks yeah
brandon's shop does suck i think is the
you know sort of the message there but
the wings are good the wings look really
good